you think you're a 10. who better at
self-improvement
self-improvement definitely women okay
rate yourself on a scale of one to ten
stands across the board oh period okay
oh my God oh God these girls would be
much prettier without the clown costumes
okay the dyed red hair I don't mind that
like I think it has its place and it can
be cute but when you combine it with a
quarter inch of foundation contoured
makeup inch long fake eyelashes and
injected lips you just look ridiculous
these girls literally look like I know
it's pretty it is pretty hilarious like
every part of their face is something
fake it's makeup over their skin lip
fillers lip gloss fake hair who knows
what the she has painted eyebrows it's
like the bimbo circuses in town it's
hilarious we're so oppressed ten keep
going ten improvements no not at all
isn't the first step towards Improvement
admitting you're not perfect you're
right we were perfect
what does the 10 mean on a scale of one
to ten ten being perfect
well what would be the [ __ ] does it mean
then technically she's right it doesn't
mean perfect it just means awesome what
still she's she it's just still it's
still a stupid argument if I say
someone's a 10 they're basically perfect
what would be perfect then on a scale of
one to ten that is not perfect really
isn't the first step towards Improvement
admitting you're not perfect
so then why would you admit that you're
a 10 which is perfect
because you should feel in your own way
that you are perfect because that's
crazy because that's manifesting that
you are a 10 12. isn't saying you're 12
admitting there's no room for
improvement
oh you got me
no
no
speaking in the microphones Universal
School we're talking about like 20 right
right so like there's always room for
improvement we just think highly of
ourselves but there's always room for
improvement we just think highly
adversely well isn't what do you think
of this [ __ ] they all say like the
confidence thing but I just like I said
I think confidence is different from
delusion I'm a 10. it's like no you're
not you're not a tent I don't think I
don't think truly confident women are
obsessed with their looks either you
know like they acknowledge their looks
and that it's important but it's not the
most important thing yeah they take care
of themselves and they're you know put
together they don't need lily leaves and
lip fillers and yeah a pound of makeup
obsessed with guys don't even like that
stuff either which is why I don't
understand the guys are like oh dude
when she has long four-inch nails and
lily leaves I'm like oh man I'll buy it
you want that purse I'm getting it like
no I think it makes this overly clownish
appearance personally I think it makes a
woman look cheap and like it's just like
it's just like all guys are into a cheap
woman for you know a cheap thrill like
it's just Band-Aids over a problem
we think highly of ourselves okay but
how highly is too highly there's not
there's not a limit there's not a limit
there's never there's not a limit too
much
being goofy these girls can't even
possibly be serious they're goofy
they're just trying to give an
interesting answer instead of giving a
real answer you can tell when people are
doing that and they're just trying so
hard it's just funny though that these
girls have like the right to be
completely delusional but if a guy ever
said that it's like what so different
he's getting roasted roasted and there's
no lily leaves for a guy you have to hit
the gym you have to make money you have
to have connections you have to do all
that [ __ ] you can't just throw on some
lashes and lip fillers and get some fake
tits and call yourself these girls work
hard at work hard at looking like bimbo
clowns it's not easy I'm telling you
it's an effort it's a level of effort
that I would never put into life yeah
it's crazy into that part of life so it
don't don't don't discount their effort
I just think that their efforts could be
better spent on like I don't know
learning how to speak in full sentences
or or you know understanding anything
about the world
besides besides contouring it doesn't
even doesn't exist yeah it's not there I
think people everybody should think
highly of themselves you should too all
the way you should have the most
comfortable okay why in the sky what is
what is more attractive to you somebody
that's down to earth and doesn't take
themselves too seriously or somebody who
walks around and thinks they're all that
um I like both I mean it's like a
mixture of both it's like it's a mixture
of both you want someone who thinks
highly of themselves but also knows yeah
well how can you be both aren't they con
aren't they a contradiction
I feel like you could think you're the
[ __ ] and have self-confidence but still
be respectful to others and not [ __ ] on
people yeah there's conceit and and Pomp
and being being considered in pompous
and then there's being confident and
thinking highly of yourself and thinking
well of yourself but it's funny because
oh you know I'm in this you know
religious Journey right now outside of
this nonsense and one of the things that
you know I'm learning that I've never
really heard before in all my years uh
as a just like a sort of non-practising
Christian or a cultural Christian is
that all of this thinking so highly of
ourselves is sort of an insult to God
like we should think highly of God and
think less of ourselves period and not
think low of ourselves just think about
ourselves less yeah like you're not a
God no you're just the time we've been
thinking about ourselves should not
eclipse the time we we spend thinking
about God and I think that this whole
thing just shows what a Godless World
we've become yeah I was going to say I
think my thing is like just it has to do
with the way you treat other people so
if I'm going to go up and talk to a girl
I'm not going to be like well I'm only a
seven or I'm only an eight so maybe she
you know because I don't have this she
won't talk to me like no you go up to
her with confidence if you're going into
to a fight or you're going into you know
any any kind of competition you're going
into a sports match there's no point of
thinking less of yourself you know what
I mean but it's different than just
going around being a [ __ ] to other
people thinking that you own the world
yeah okay is it possible to improve
without taking accountability no I can't
yeah you have to be self-aware and
accountable what's the last mistake you
took accountability for
um I literally can't get past how
ridiculous these girls look for always
being late okay why uh why is it often
said that women are notoriously late
[Music]
how much did
you like um
I mean this one in the middle like
what are you doing honey okay
um she's a pretty girl too she didn't
have all that [ __ ] yeah that's what I'm
saying I wouldn't
15 minutes yeah if they're coming as
long as there's if they're communicating
you give them 10 minutes I feel like
it's like 10 minutes if they're not
communicating and if they are like I was
distracted what are we even talking
about 10 minutes of what 10 minutes to
who if if your date is late or whatever
oh if they're communicating 10 minutes
imagine it's like I'm stuck in traffic
my dog had the shits I'll be there 11
minutes late ah yeah sorry buddy maybe
if you weren't communicating like what
these girls are crazy guy when preparing
for a special night out on the town how
much consideration do you give towards
being on time
none I have 15 minutes to make it to a
club so and I still got to go change and
get ready why do modern women have more
of a problem submitting to a husband
than they do submitting to an employer
what was the question in other words
why do women think they are free I'm
sure we're going to get an intellectual
answer out of this one but slaves where
their husband and children because the
employer
give us money our husbands give us
headaches
so men don't give you money I thought
men were providers they are but I know
for some get paid on the first and 15. I
don't know with him you don't know if
he's gonna pay the Portage or bring home
you don't know if your your employer is
just gonna fire you if you have a like
that's the thing that I find funny about
the feminist movement is that they've
tricked women into thinking that it's
good to be dependent upon a company that
sees you as a number rather than a
husband that loves you I don't know if
my husband that loves me is gonna take
care of me or give me food it's like
what and it's also taken away men's
drive to really really push and strive
because they end up becoming complacent
and relying on their women for half the
income it's crazy [ __ ] it's crazy talk
cat calling it's not
it's not appreciated there's a
difference from being creepy and then
just trying Charming yeah and
complimenting cat calling is not
complimenting
oh they're such NPCs what do you think
they mean by that if you're charming or
you're or you're being creepy it means
how attractive you are if you're ugly
and you go up to this girl you could say
the same exact thing no some that's what
it's like no some some people can give
you a compliment and and it just feels
like a compliment and it's nice some men
oh there's there's Air Supply guy okay
Air Supply guy at Grandma's retirement
community he's one of the younger people
there at the parties and I call them
their supply guy because he has the same
hairdo as the lead singer from Air
Supply in the 80s and he is so creepy to
me like super creepy he'll be like I'll
be walking up I'm going to a party at
the clubhouse in the retirement
community like I'm the youngest person
there every everyone's you know a lot of
the people are in there 65 to you know
100 is their age like I'm going up to
some hot club and he'll he'll do this
like oh yeah Haram wow hey have you you
know like this disgust and I get this
disgusting feeling and I just I avert my
eyes and I walk right by him and I
hadn't seen him in a while and I just
saw him and he I so it's like fresh
again and it's gross that and then
there's another gentleman there who's
older who like you know compliments me
on my appearance all the time and I'm
and it's sweet and it doesn't gross me
out so there's very different ways of it
unless I'm misunderstanding no I think
there's multiple parts to it I agree
with that like you can be creepy like
damn mama you looking sexy like that's
just weird but I think that even if a
Dude is coming up and saying a more
innocent comment but he's like closer to
their age and he's not attractive
they're gonna be like ah they do that
these young girls are you know every
they're victims if you go to an uglier
dude no you're right those young girls
are victims they complain about
literally everything that they don't
like so he was ugly so instead of just
saying oh that was sweet but I'm not
interested in him it's it they may they
may turn it on to being a creepy thing
yeah I hate when guys are creepy at bars
though like when oh my God that's the
worst when you're at a bar or you're
with people or like they get too drunk
and they just start being weird with
girls that's like the worst but don't I
don't want to hear that these girls
don't dress all sexy to get attention
give me a break from the behavior of
approaching a woman actually look like
not complimenting
what does the behavior of approaching a
woman respectfully look like
it looks like a man coming up to you and
just giving you a literally a normal
compliment like your outfit also
probably talking to you about yourself
other than talking to you about your
looks and what you look like instead of
being like damn girl that ass is fat how
about be like wow like you're a
beautiful woman wow that tusha that tush
is plump I mean they're right you
shouldn't be walking up to a girl I mean
like damn [ __ ] those boobs like no
that's terrible that's gross but they're
exaggerating and acting like that
happens all the time and maybe it does
but if that happens all the time they
need to ask themselves where am I where
am I and why am I here and why am I
coming to this place with all these
skeevy jerk men go somewhere classier
when you go to the Four Seasons Lounge
and you dress like a lady and you sit at
the bar and have a drink with your
friends yeah you're gonna get hit on but
it's not going to be quite as disgusting
and sleazy what's your name
something like that other than
complimenting your physical if a man
then why do you get all done gives you a
compliment does it have different
meaning to you if it's the exact same
compliment yes a woman gives it to me
then it means way more damn girl your
ass is looking fast it's literally
nothing but a compliment from a woman
no it doesn't how does a compliment from
a woman mean anything the fattest girls
I know on Instagram get hundreds of
comments of how stunning they are it's a
lie you know I I said this compliments
from women do have value because they're
given a lot of times women can be really
catty and shitty to each other so when
like you're in the ladies room at a club
and some woman is like oh my God that
dress is amazing like thanks man like
you didn't expect it and it feels good
it is it's like a nice little it's like
a bro thing I guess is the closest thing
I could try to make you understand to
make you understand if a man calls but
it doesn't mean that but they're saying
a compliment from a man is worthless
absolutely untrue if a man also says
that's a really nice dress wow yeah
that's it you know that same exact
comment it is also a nice compliment and
it also feels good so they're just like
they just say things just to say them
swear give to a man who maybe wants to
come up and say something nice without
being perceived as creepy
approach a woman nicely say I just want
to let you know you're beautiful thank
you yeah and
so you could maybe don't make if she's
into it stand there wait a second but if
you could tell she's like like then walk
away yeah go into it like not thinking
that you're gonna get something out of
it
do women often find attractive men cute
and romantic when an ugly one doing the
exact same thing is creepy honestly yes
it's probably rude but yes so then isn't
it entirely subjective yes so then if so
why should a guy even bother trying to
be romantic unless the woman already
shows interest
well I think it it depends on the girl
also like it depends on who I mean if an
ugly man came out to me and was like
you're beautiful I'd be like thank you
why aren't you also saying that it
depends on the guy
yeah yeah it depends on like
she said like if an ugly guy comes up to
me and is like oh like you look very
beautiful someone that she thinks ugly
but let's say I don't think they're ugly
that's the difference so like attract
everyone has scale yeah beauty is
there's some baddies with some ugly ass
dudes I don't know hit the gym get
bigger be a cool interesting guy I mean
if you're ugly like oh that's your only
choice what else are you gonna do yeah
we definitely definitely get more into
personality oh 100 than guys do and even
quicker think about early celebrities
earlier there's some goofy looking
celebrities that are dating supermodels
well that's a lot look at Pete Davidson
he's not like a bad looking guy but he's
out here with the most beautiful girls
in the world I think I I think he looks
like Beetlejuice women will often say
things like all men cheat or men only
want one thing are women more likely to
accept negative generalizations about
men than they are about women
oh yeah yeah why is that I think so
because a lot of guys just
a lot of guys are different there is
like a 50 of them that are like good
like they just they're really nice and
respectful but there's other like ones
that just don't have that
she didn't even understand the question
remember the [ __ ] they want okay
but why is it when it comes to calling
out female Behavior it depends on the
woman
because women are weird as well yeah
women do the same [ __ ] there's some
Chasey ass girls out here in Vegas
especially okay yeah what's your
favorite kind of apple tangerines like
they're not even answering they don't
even understand my questions this is
really hard and I know that this is
edited to show dingbat women and I
wouldn't think about young women who
just have no idea what's going on at
least these two aren't you know don't
look like clown worlds like the you know
they're I can't stand a nose piercing
but that's a personal choice like this
one in the red jacket she's very pretty
she doesn't have a ton of makeup on
she's pretty natural like that's a look
at least that I think is lovely but
still Channel but you're not you're not
one of them so
if women don't need men
why do women date men for their own
pleasure
what do you mean
we don't need them but we want them we
want the attention we like the attention
uh I don't know maybe boredom
um the need to not be alone well why not
just date a woman
why not just date a woman
attention Okay so why do women date men
because they have a penis okay so if
women want dick
how is that different than men sexually
objectifying women
[Music]
have more feel
ings come behind you
can anyone ever just go you know good
point I hadn't thought of it that way
can't any of these people ever say that
no they just gotta dig in on their
stupidity dig in deeper why do women
date men
dick
okay how is that different than men
objectifying women sexually
damn that's a good ass question I don't
have an answer
really can't provide asking you
and how come when you ask a woman what
she brings to the table that's not her
answer because they're not being true to
themselves okay
interesting all right wait what would he
what do you ask so why do women complain
about being sexually objectified when
you think that the JJ is pretty much all
they're bringing
that's a good question wow
um
next question Stephen you don't have an
answer look at that asking you shall
receive wow you know I'm not even gonna
lie like the black chicks they they
usually like do have like more why like
like better answers than like the dumb
White Chicks yeah they have am I
tripping or yeah I don't want to speak
for or speak as if I know a lot about it
but I generally think they have a good
solid understanding of male female
relations more so than these dumb white
NPC like liberal girls that's how I see
it I think you're right I think it's
because they're parents to be honest
like I feel like they raise them with
more like traditional views and guide
like guidance in a sense you know what I
mean like black southern moms like
they're not playing around you're right
all right do you think a woman's body
count matters in dating
well
yes okay when guys when guys guys look
at it yes because
for females to have sex we have to give
them consent right yes okay so it's so
when a guy has sex with a female is he
he's he scored basically that's yeah
that was just smart I mean like I just
kind of just proved my point the woman
is like the goalie you know the the
we're playing hockey the woman's the
goalie the the net is you know home
based and the dudes you know Alex
Ovechkin skating around trying to trying
to get you know get his Gold by that's
just how the dynamic is though it's like
when a dude and a girl are out it's like
I don't know it's weird I don't want to
talk about this Haram you know what the
truth is though like women some of these
women will that that we've seen on these
body count videos will say no it doesn't
matter but all of them will lie about
their body count if asked yeah I know
you know okay it doesn't matter why are
you lying yeah it definitely matters we
like to say it doesn't and it shouldn't
but it does now the fact that you also
like women does it matter to lesbian
women the same way that it matters to
men no
that's interesting how do you like
explain the difference there I feel like
a lot of times like when it comes to
that it's the idea of you being like
more experienced not saying that people
are against like messing with like a
first-time person but that's such a like
emotional attachment experience if I'm
the first person taking your virginity
well if you come across somebody that's
already like know what they're doing
then yeah you're kind of a little bit
more comfortable with that so I don't
know why that's different why do you
think it is that women like guys with
more experience or like having like a
girl doesn't go for like a virgin you
know girls don't go like when when girls
are virgins they're usually not going
out like looking to lose their virginity
so you're talking about more experienced
a more experienced girl or woman is
gonna want somebody with experience in
the hopes that when they're together
it's good for her and he's not a dud but
that doesn't necessarily mean anything
so that's mine I know in a queer
Community it's definitely a little
different yeah well if a woman's body
count doesn't matter why would a woman
ever [ __ ] shame another woman
because females are haters
they be hating on each other well if
women don't even trust other women then
why should men trust women
this dude just like like I said we
provide the Virgin okay well if women
provide the vajayjay and Men provide the
resources how is dating not just a loose
form of prostitution
it is I never said it wasn't okay so
then why do women get offended when you
call them prostitutes because they hate
getting told the truth yeah okay yeah
interesting why do women hate being told
the truth because we are very
hard-headed and we don't like to listen
I think a lot of women oh my God she's a
hot [ __ ] this one I like her I almost
feel bad it's like go back to the
brainwashing you you're too woken up
it's fine
when they're when they're wrong and they
just want to know argument
you have no return where you're just
like I just have to be right I don't
know why it's a hard thing aren't men
more likely to concede even if they're
not wrong
oh yeah why do we have the expression
being the bigger man
damn I never thought about that why is
it often said that women are
women are I think
we're agreeable but in a different way
how so
um I feel like like you said with that
to like please a partner but I feel like
women are people Pleasers like just
regular in their everyday life like I
will see myself or see other women
whether it's like in the workforce
whether it's when it comes to being a
parent whether it's your relationships
with other women
um we'll just kind of take a back seat
just to be like okay cool like whatever
we'll go with the flow with that but I
feel like yeah when it comes to men with
their Partners they'll concede first but
I don't know about like their
interactions with other men if that's
the case well how can you be a people
pleaser if you also need to be right
it's a double-edged sword people are
complicated like it's complicated she's
right people are complicated it's a good
video thank you guys so much for
watching inside my Academy people have
been having crazy ass results lately
this dude's already making thousands of
dollars a day with e-commerce it's been
pretty wild so if you want to join um
the link is inside the description you
can join the server for free check it
out and join if you like pretty cool
stuff thank you guys see ya thanks guys
bye
oh my
God
I'd rather riding on the wall won't last
long
[Music]